the u.s. women's soccer team will have
extra competition on Sunday when it goes
for its fourth World Cup two men's
tournaments will play their final games
on the same day Team USA's Megan Rapinoe
calls that a ridiculous and
disappointing distraction Roxana
sub-areas Lyon France where the US will
play in Sunday's final Roxana I remember
covering this a few years ago I'm
surprised to hear about the controversy
now about the women playing but then the
men are playing after they still get all
the love like they're still doing very
well right it is a controversy well FIFA
says that having all three games on the
same day will actually draw more
attention to the sport in any case
anticipation is building ahead of the
final here on Sunday we'll see the
reigning World Cup champions take on a
relative newcomer here the Netherlands
with 24 goals adding up to six victories
Team USA seems poised to play its way
into World Cup history what do you think
your team has that other teams don't
have how to win at all cost those
moments came when the team edged past
Spain knocked out host nation France and
broke English hearts while sipping tea
that celebration by co-captain Alex
Morgan stirred a bit of controversy but
today she's brushing it off it wasn't it
hit England in any way there is some
sort of double standard for females in
sports to feel like we you know have to
be humble in our successes and have to
celebrate but not too much next up the
Netherlands this is only the second time
the team has even made it to a World Cup
we work so hard to to deliver and to do
well and it's so nice to be in a final
the battle will also be in the streets
and at the stadium
with fans dressed in orange of course we
gotta beat us a piece of cake on the red
white and blue
cygwin in the final it's very confident
our girls yeah they're gonna go all the
way yeah absolutely if they do go all
the way if the u.s. wins here on Sunday
it will join Germany as the only teams
to win this tournament twice in a row
gale
well we know who we're rootin for Thank
You Roxana Saberi